so we're here in San Diego for this
year's comic-con and that basically it's
crowded it's one of the most crowded
years if everyone has ever said they've
seen there's people all over the place
it's sold out all four days and I can
really see why you know at the core it's
still very much a comic book driven
place I mean you still have boots with
illustrations and old school you know
first spider-man's and things like that
but you're also seeing a lot more movies
video games and films and all of that
coming together television shows is
making it more of a pop culture
spectacle so you can find people here
that are they don't even read comic
books they say they don't read comic
books but they're here to have fun
they're here to dress up they're here to
laugh with their friends and just sort
of take part in this larger pop-culture
oriented festival of complete madness so
we knew coming to this year's comic-con
that we were going to see a lot of
Hollywood a lot of film and television
and movies but we kind of didn't know
how much it was going to be Hollywood
driven Tim Burton who's doing Alice in
Wonderland was here to debut some
footage and you know so 6500 person
theater to our line to get in two hours
just to see it and guess who pops out on
stage with Tim Burton Johnny Depp girls
are screaming they're going nuts and it
doesn't even really feel like you're at
a comic book convention it's like you're
at a red carpet premiere and really
that's what we're seeing a lot more of
is just Hollywood has gotten its claws
into comic books and it's for the better
we're seeing incredible movies that are
going to be coming out this fall and
it's just exciting to be here
you